Hãy hảy hảy mốt thử tấm, cơ thủ tướng phía trong thân xin ở trong trang
ở trong mặt tại Tuan Hinh phát Thái Lan để thăm xa phía nếu trân
nhân chứng trong vụ án liên quan đến yêu cầu bán nghiệm chức vụ thủ tướng.
Vụ việc mắt muôn từ vãn kia m được công bố cho thấy cuộc trọt chuyển
địa thoại giữa bà phía thung thân và trụ tệ thương viện cơ gùi chiều hôn xanh
làm giới lên cáo mục viーバng đặc đức nghiêm trọng.
Phíanh toàn giò bán bị sấu thử nỡi sĩ đệ trình lên Tuan Hinh phát,
yêu cầu phán quyết về việc bà phía thung thân có tích tục đảm nhiệm chức vụ hay không?
Chứ vì đường trần Tuan Hinh phát thung báo, giò tình chức quan trọng đưa biện đình gú ra
hình ngày và âm thanh chung quá trình thăm vẫn sẽ không được phát sống.
Đồng thời những người thăm dưới không được phép phát tảm, hay trình dựa chỉ thế lên quan
có thể gây dựng nhầm cho công chống.
Kéo lực trình, phíanh phóng ngày 20,5 và tuán hình phát sẽ công bố phán quyết phóng ngày 20,5.
Đấy sẽ là mất lửa dân quan trọng, lên quan đến vị trí của bà phía thung thân trong bộ máy chính phủ thay lần.